يوم جديد من ايام حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
هنا على محور جنوب شرقي البلاد حيث يواصل
الجيش الاوكراني هجومه المضاد يخرج الجنود
الاوكرانيون في مهمه استطلاع ورصد لمواقع
تمركز القوات الروسيه
نبحث عن اهداف العدو بين احزمه الغابات
وعن ملاجئهم وتجمع الياتهم العسكريه
مهمه فريق كيلي تحديد احداثيات التمركز
القطع العسكري الروسيه وهو بحث شاق
بالنسبه للفريق في سهول متراميه الاطراف
صفه
نشعر بالاحباط لان عدونا ايضا لديه قدره
على اخفاء معداته لكن ان لم نجدها في
المره الاولى فسنجدها في المره الثانيه او
الثالثه
في الاثناء يتولى فريق ليشي مهمه تفحيخ
طائراته الانتحاريه
يمكن لهذه القنبله تدمير دبابه معاديه اذا
اصطدمت بالمحرك ويمكنها ضرب المدرعات
ونقلات الجند كما يمكننا بواسطتها استهداف
خنادق العدو يعني هذه الطائره رخيصه جدا
لكن ضررها كبير بالنسبه للمعدات الروسيه
اذا قارنت طائره انتحاريه كهذه بدبابه
فسيرها 500 دولار مقابل مليوني دولار سعر
الدبابه
اصبحت هذه المسيرات سلاح رعب على جبهات
القتال فبمقدورها كما يقول الجيش
الاوكراني ان تبطئ تقدم القوات البريه
الروسيه وتخمد نيران الدبابات والمدفعيه
وتغير سير المعارك على الارض
الطائرات الانتحاريه تستطيع الرد وتغيير
الوضع في ساحه المعركه فالمسيره بامكانها
التحرك اسرع من المدفعيه مثلا ومن ثم
تغيير الوضع في الميدان لذا فان اوكرانيا
تعمل على انشاء وحده عسكريه خاصه فيما
باتا يعرف بسلاح مسيرات حيث تؤهل حاليا
عشره الاف جندي اوكراني لهذه المهمه املا
في احراز تقدم في الهجوم المعاكس الذي
بداته قبل شهور ليسكر راما الجزيره